you were so deliberate I feel like on
the show like when when you met your guy
is his name's Gianni Jr can see Giovanni
no Gianna yeah Gianni and in the same
guy the whole time yeah he was inside
yeah you were oh my God like you were so
deliberate you were like this is my guy
and you took your relationship so
seriously yeah like and you take your
business so seriously like it
you know it seemed like in the beginning
it was like wow you're like the snooky
character she's such a mess and like you
were just so
turned out to be so focused and
deliberate oh yeah I knew what I was
doing yeah yeah I knew exactly what I
was saying and you
you were like that's all that anybody
was snooky like you were like the like
the the thing because that was the
hottest mess and the most fun yeah but
if you remember the the first season of
Jersey Shore they were like why do you
want to go down the shore I was like I
want to find love I want to find my
Guido I want to have tan babies like
that's the goal here and then I found
Gianni and then we had tan babies
so I always manifest my life that's epic
and
um
when did all the the businesses start
cropping up oh [__] right away I feel
like I started to get crazy endorsements
in Miami but it was like endorsements
where I knew I was going to regret it
later in life like at the time I was
like oh this is so cool like a cigarette
endorsement condoms like all this like
trash like vodka and I said no to it
because I knew Like My Future Self
I'm not gonna want that you know like as
a part of my brand in my career so I got
crazy things like that but then
eventually I was just like you know what
this TV shit's not gonna last forever
which it didn't we had like a huge break
I was like let me open up a store let me
um you know when I got the kids let me
do a stroller line let me do mommy
things
so I I always knew I had to do something
and I always want to do something so I'm
not the type to like sit at home all day
and do nothing like I want to have a
business I want to make money I wanna
hustle because I've been doing that
since high school
that's awesome with that how many of
your businesses are with JWoww
I don't have any Virginia none no none
we only had our show together right yeah
um does Jay Wow have a ton of businesses
too yeah she's got tanning
um she has a clothing line
she's um doing behind the scenes work
she wants to do she really wants to be
behind and like yeah she doesn't want to
be in front as much and and she was when
she got married to her dude that she met
on the show but that didn't work out
yeah divorced yeah yeah that guy was a
cook huh
wait no he's a nice guy but them
together did not it wasn't working do
you like shopping on Amazon I do and
good news is Stevo's butt wipes for your
butthole are available on Amazon and if
you want a real bundle of a deal you can
get Stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
plus Stephen's butthole destroyer and
Stevo's butt wipes for your butthole
it's the butthole bundle available on
Amazon right now yeah
dude